you just did a show in new york last
saturday which was great sold out this
is fun um
you talked about on the show and i've
heard you talk about before
your
invisibility cloak as an asian man
um where like if i wanted to be
anonymous or hidden you felt that you
could do it oh yeah just don't
uh stick your face into someone else's
face and you you know you could just
walk by
[Laughter]
do you
i'm curious at how that or one you could
one love you to like unpack that further
but also it's tied to or can it be is it
tied to
this concept of otherness that i feel
like the asian american community lives
with um where you're not and you got it
some a bit i think we ran for mayor
where you're not really a new yorker
even though you've been here for 25
years yeah uh
and anything you did that wasn't
i don't know like traditional new yorker
you said your favorite subway station
was times square which is by the way
where you live and if you listen that
full quote you're like yeah it's my
favorite one because it's the one i take
all the time
um
like oh he's a tourist you had political
cartoons that were in my opinion
offensive and um
little backlash from those who usually
call out those sort of things as
offensive um like
does that visibility cloak you're
talking about play into the otherness of
the asian american community am i
overthinking that i don't know what you
think well one of the things that jay
and i talked about which i found
hysterical uh where he said uh
on the podcast he was like people just
don't give a [ __ ] about the internal
lives of asian americans
which i laughed at because
i thought well it's pretty true and then
he talked about the tension of writing a
book around something that people don't
give a [ __ ] about right uh so
i think that's the way that um you adapt
over time uh and
i would say that people there's like a
spectrum of racism where it's like you
know that anti-black racism is much more
serious and destructive uh and so then
if you complain about racism towards
like another group then everyone's like
yeah you know
that's part of it yeah that's part of
jay's point
um
and so
certainly that otherness
and
let me say that
uh i feel very american uh i got into
some trouble because uh you know i wrote
something that frankly assumed asian
americans were americans
and i got into trouble with with you
know with people who
um who somehow imagined that i was
calling our americanness into question
when i was really assuming it yeah uh
i love this country i mean my parents
immigrated here and i think um you know
at the same time like i don't have any
illusions about the fact that
um that people
perceive
who i am at least partially as an asian
guy and you know there are certain um
things that come with that and uh you
know as like a an adult you know like
there are some things that i took for
granted including this invisibility
cloak i was joking about but it turns
out that i was completely wrong about
the invisibility cloak because now when
i walk the streets of new york or
anyplace else people are like yang
you're no longer in this yeah where's my
thousand bucks and i'm like oh you know
like
oh that's that's different but i'd say
it's positive different and i'm trying
to make the most of this i do want to
activate asian americans
that are
right now disengaged in some of these
issues and i'm really happy to say that
my campaign did that like i met a lot of
people from different communities uh who
said
uh look you know you may be interested
in politics and politics you made me
care and i think that's a good thing you
know i think that assuming that degree
of
involvement is like a sign of confidence
and maturation
which i love
though i will also say that if someone
decides that politics is just anxiety
producing and depressing and they want
to ignore it for an extended period of
time i'm with you there too it's like
you know like don't worry about it you
know it's like you you
yeah
because of
a lot of the things you know like
frankly the media drum beat um which
we're going to we're going to talk about
the recent article about kamala but like
that the media
is definitely race obsessed in a way
that i certainly think most asian
americans are not like most asian
americans
in my experience are just trying to make
good things happen for themselves and
their family uh and
yeah like that and if there are media
products that they want to consume that
have a lot of asian faces there are a
lot of those products that are being
made in people's native countries you
know like a lot of the koreans i know
just watch korean dramas and like
perfectly happy
that said also i am of that group of
people that loves it when
uh creators and artists of uh different
communities like are trying to make that
happen in part cause it's so hard so
like i do support asian american
uh writers and artists and and the rest
of it because i feel
the
the resistance
that's a good that's a good segment of
this last question i ask you so i think
it's not i don't i think by that we've
looked at some numbers so we could pull
them up if we want to dive in further
but your point that most asian americans
you think are not race obsessed i think
most americans are not race obsessed and
i know that people have told me that's a
uh or you know the classic white guy
saying i don't see racism is a place of
privilege and i agree with that but i
also you could also be true to the other
extent that not it's still not everybody
thinking racism all the time or seeing
race and only race but my question is
you know at least from my own personal
experience as i was a straight white guy
my whole thing is i'm trying to be an
ally trying not to be an [ __ ] like on
most days um
and
my question is what
what should non-asians know about being
asian in the uh or simply how could they
not
you know something like me how can i not
be a dick or is there something and i've
never asked you before but it's
something that you wish
folks of other races or maybe just white
people knew about being asian that isn't
talked about or you've never said or
others haven't said
well you and i have worked together for
years so clearly
i've got a lot of this through osmosis i
think and i've lived the community many
ways oh i you know i think that the the
main thing that most asian americans
would want were just to be regarded as
three-dimensional human beings with uh
thoughts feelings hopes ambitions
a sense of humor etc etc and not to be
reduced to any trade including race i
think that's what most people want yeah
and i my favorite quote from you on the
presidential when someone had said well
you are
repurposing and promoting a stereotype
when you use a math slogan or things
like that and you said maybe but you
know it's also not the asian american
stereotype is standing next to joe biden
and running for president right yeah
like the entire thing is like you're
reinforcing asian stereotypes it's like
are you [ __ ] kidding me like i'm
running for president it's like the
least asian thing you can do
so shut the [ __ ] up is what i'd wanted
to say but of course you know you can't
say that stuff when you're running props
you have to be like oh i understand
people can take a joke but internally i
was like like look a [ __ ] round you
it's like what am i doing here you know
and i will say too that like this is one
of the things that irritate irritated
the [ __ ] out of me it's like you find
like
seven
irritating
but you know asian americans with like
organizations that barely exist and be
like oh look we found these asian
americans to say like andrew yen doesn't
speak for us it's like one i would never
pretend to speak for everyone in the
community but two it's like do something
you know what i mean
you know but then the fact that the
media like would like to like to beat
that you know why because
it serves the media's narrative and you
know who it doesn't serve
like everyone else like the american
public all of us you know
like people who want good things to
happen asian america like that [ __ ] does
not help but you know like that there's
like this yeah it's like a device you
know it and it's something it's
happening to jay too by the way and so
you know like at the end of my
conversation with jay we we had a moment
about
that
yeah so i'll i'll drop that i love well
it's it's we we live this world where a
lot of people are pretending or claiming
to be
championing progress or usually the
blockade uh to that progress well they
have just a very very narrow definition
and it's around
social media [ __ ] and things that
don't matter to the vast majority of
people um and so then you know you just
like get caught up in that and then like
that like that's the coin of the realm
it's one of the diseases of this time
oh it's where we live every day brother
that's why i mean look and we appreciate
all of you for listening it's one it's a
place where you can actually have a
conversation on this that isn't
it's gray it's not black and white most
things are
um maybe that could be jay's book uh
title instead of the loneliest americans
not black or white
[Music]
you